[Music]
and welcome back to Hannity here now
with reaction to my opening monologue on
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
is testimony today on Capitol Hill and
the corruption that is within Muller
special counsel author of the book
trumped up how criminalization of
political differences in dangers
democracy Harvard Law School professor
Alan Dershowitz is back with us first
professor let me get your reaction of
the hearing and more particularly to
these this email exchange mm-hm and the
the depth in terms of this one guy
struck taps into almost everything we
have discussed for a year does the FBI
not have any other employees because it
seems like he's it well first of all I
want to wish everybody a Happy Hanukkah
and in 12 days a Merry Christmas they to
do yes and let me give you some legal
context to this I think this is a
terrible problem it's a very serious
problem it's a problem not only a
perception of bias but the reality of
bias here and so any defendant who gets
indicted by the Muller Group is going to
be able to challenge their indictment in
court and here's the way Muller is going
to defend it he's going to say look our
statutes prohibit me from considering
political affiliation and hiring people
I just hired the best people they all
happen to be Democrats who supported
Clinton the response to that is going to
be well maybe not political affiliation
but bias within a felt political
affiliation these folks who wrote these
emails they should have been sensible
enough to recuse themselves immediately
they have a strong bias just like
Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg has
expressed a very strong bias against
President to trump and I hope she will
recuse herself in any case involving the
president directly so should there be a
special counsel appointed no because I
don't see evidence of crimes but I think
what Muller should do is appoint an
ethics consultant somebody like a former
Attorney General Mike McKay Z a former
head of the FBI Louis Freeh to come in
and do a complete evaluation of
everybody understand
everything that he needs it with to me
this is so transparent the team that
he's put together you know Andrew
Weissman you've been up do you know this
guy he didn't belong on that team you
know how many how many overturns are
there nine zero you've argued before the
Supreme Court yeah it's a very it's a
very good question Andrew Weissman has a
reputation of being an excellent very
tough somewhat zealous lawyer I didn't
know anything about his political
affiliation I actually had a case
against him not so long ago he's very
very good he never should have sent that
email congratulating Sally Sally a
should not have been congratulated I
wrote an op-ed piece since you're the
acting Attorney General it's the law how
about withholding exculpatory evidence
how about in in other cases what could
only be deemed as beyond aggressive
tactics to get conviction I agree with
you as a civil liberties lawyer I am
appalled when prosecutors withhold
exculpatory evidence whether they
discussed or Republicans we have to
defend the civil liberties of all
Americans starting with the President
and there are so many pardons out there
who say all right what civil
libertarians but we got to get rid of
this president so let's civil liberties
be put aside and that's what some of
these emails suggest that they were
prepared to do anything to get this
president and that's a bias what about
this one particular text message and we
only have less than 400 there are over
10,000 can't wait for the rest of them
but I want to believe the path that you
threw out for consideration in Andy's
office I believe they're talking about
mccabe personally it's a guess i haven't
confirmed it that there's no way Trump
gets elected if we follow that path as
what she's what they're saying I'm
afraid we can't take that risk it's like
an insurance policy in the unlikely
event you die before you're 40 that's
chilling to me that email that you know
is that I think I think there has to be
an investigation of that but I don't
want criminal investigations we should
start with ethics investigations
congressional investigations I always
suggested a nonpartisan Commission like
the 9/11 Commission but
you start with the special counsel
you're immediately saying there must be
crime here and I think that's wrong on
both sides so I'm opposed to the
Republicans call for a special counsel
just as I was opposed for the
appointment of Muller as a special
counsel we have to get the
criminalization out of our system and
start looking simply to learn the truth
and we have to find out everything we
can about any bias of anybody in the
Mulla probe otherwise it's simply not
gonna have credibility and it's going to
be subject to challenge by any criminal
defendant who was indicted by this
special counsel all right professor love
your keen intellect if people want to
have some fun following you on Twitter
against Lawrence tribe it's it's a bit
of an LS you know I challenged him to a
debate and he said well maybe in may
well you know Caesars let's have a
debate now I will tell you professor I
will have I will give you two seats here
on my set great it will be an open
debate and I'll stay out of it how's
that I accept one-on-one you got it